did you know that we're doing newlywed
game have you heard about this newly wet
yeah what's that it's gonna be Brent and
his swinging wife yeah versus Ronnie and
his young fiancee like is this like a
newlywed kind of game there you go but
you see we call it newlywed because you
know those guys like it wet yeah you
know it's a second natural natural
juices juices juices juices hey Gary
so I'm betting on Brent big-time on this
I think oh you already when you say
bedding I have you place no but I'll
take somebody's money if they're why are
you betting on Brent because I think
Brent's trying to get this whole sex
thing going on with his wife with other
people I think he's got to be so tuned
in to her that he's got to listen to
everything that she wants to keep that
deal girly Brent is so busy talking and
his wife is busy talking that they
probably don't they're just talking talk
a lot yeah but I think that I think
Brent has to listen cuz Brent needs to
he's the one who really wants to keep
that thing going
I heard Brent was talking some [ __ ]
saying he's gonna cream Ronnie oh he's
very calm he's as confident as he was in
the IQ test
Brent why are you so confident that
you'll win well it's because like Gary
said with my wife I've had to really get
down and have some really deep
conversations about every thought that's
in her head right so and the same with
her with me so you think you're gonna
kick Ronnie's ass a newlywed game yeah
yeah definitely
cuz Ronnie doesn't pay attention to his
girl well well here's the thing Ronnie
and Stephanie are great together but
Ronnie you know Ronnie right here's the
problem first of all you know this
became a wrestling match when did this
become a [ __ ] rest well it's a
competition to see who wins [ __ ]
why because it's you're going up against
Brandon's wife okay yeah for what a sex
game I didn't agree not a sex you know
agree to a [ __ ] newsy with me that's
what it is
that's what it's not what it sounding
like what were you been talking to no
I'm listening to what the [ __ ] going
on we just named it newlywed game cuz
you guys are always talking about sex
but it's the newly we just [ __ ]
comment about how Brent knows everything
about his wife's sex life and all this
but again you do not listen okay I
telling me something
jeez yeah it's like I'm looking
wrestling match with this [ __ ]
comes in right I don't know my [ __ ]
girlfriend when it says you don't he
says you don't listen
[ __ ] all I said was all I said was
because he's trying to get a sex deal
going with her he just listens to her it
won't listen to anything then I just
talking about him not about you that you
[ __ ] money on him okay whoa whoa
those are fightin words
hey Greg Gary break your [ __ ] money
on who you bangin I was gonna be but
this breakdown I don't know son became a
[ __ ] wrestling match well you're
making a boy figure he knows everything
so why should I he's gonna win okay good
it's a competition we find out by doing
the competition okay great so you think
you'll be Ronnie yeah based on the fact
that you're more tuned in to your wife
yeah and I think that he does this this
arguing bit with her as a defense
mechanism so we get close he doesn't
have to have that real intimate close
conversation with her if he's doing this
bit okay this is arguing in psychology
do you feel Ronnie's relationship
[ __ ] know everything do you feel
Ronnie's relationship needs fixing in a
way well I think you did like that now
he's there you got a problem you don't
like that no I don't knows everything if
you listen to Stephanie the way you
listen to us you're probably gonna lose
Wow
Judi pay your money on [ __ ] Brent oh
I was going to bet on you but now
now you're yelling again you're not
listening I'm listening first of all
it's not a sexual game it's a newlywed
game yet okay no what do you eat on okay
I'm telling you the truth I never lie to
you I don't I lie to you
no all right never said you lie I'm not
lying I'm just trying to figure out who
to put my money on that's all Brent I
came in here to say there's quite a few
people in the office who think Ron and
Ronnie and Stephanie or did you take how
many people did you point it we pulled
about 20 and most people thought Brent
and Caitlin would win but it was
relatively what did another numbers it
was 13 people think Brent's gonna win in
77 people think Ronnie's gonna win I
happen to agree with you Howard I think
that Brent and Caitlin I've been around
them they're an awesome couple but they
talk constantly they don't stop talking
and I don't know how anyone can retain
all that information you say maybe they
don't even listen to you so busy talking
yeah so I think Ronnie's got a shot well
I sat and thought about it long and hard
last night I've been on the road with
Ronnie and Stephanie for a while and I
can tell you that a Stephanie knows
everything about Ronnie because she
doesn't want to piss Ronnie off right
yeah cause it's like walking around a
landmine needs to know because if she
says something wrong with Joe now the
other thing is Caitlin is so aggressive
and and comes off like kind of like
she's got a dude vibe to her like right
now [ __ ] she wants to get laid as
dudes we mentally we don't invest when
we think like that you thought this
through I think a scientist and I think
a Stephanie knows more about Ronnie I
don't think Caitlin knows as much about
Brent as Brent may know about her and
I've seen Ronnie compromise muffiny I've
been on the road he puts on music was he
put on the pop channel he doesn't [ __ ]
it you pop [ __ ] they've just been
together a lot longer they just know
each other you're like Sigmund Freud jr.
if you like to hear a strong counter
to that decline buddy in the office that
thinks ronnie has zero chance who is
that
they'll be chris wild again for having a
game go ahead Chris what do you think
where are you come in here get mad at
Julie for for his soliloquy Ron I want
to bet on this like real money and I
want to hear everyone's opinion my
problem Suze away let him talk they're
going I hang out with Brent and Kaitlin
all the time they're a great couple
they're a lovely couple they're wild but
they love each other right I see
absolutely zero evidence of love between
us I have no interest in what she has to
say are you gonna win again
she's gonna say when it's all about you
cuz you're the star and you're the diva
how can she compete with you everything
so okay you say Brett and Kaitlin based
on the fact that you think Brent and
Kaitlin are more in love this is your
assessment not mom knowing love why
Indian swinging yeah but that has
nothing to do with love right that's sex
and love can be two very separate things
and maybe if he wants to do it she loves
him enough to allow him to do it well
good for him I met who you bent on
what's your theory you seem to have a
lot of things listen I happen to think
they're both lug heads you don't really
understand women but Oh first girlfriend
both [ __ ] I could be neither of you but
as much as it oh really oh absolutely
yes you're saying you're you've been
with your girlfriend seriously now I
know this girl better in four months
than these idiots know 100% your side
I do believe Brent will win this because
why he's like an idiot savant he
he remembers facts like if he hears his
girlfriend say something or his fiancee
wife say something he'll remember where
is Ronnie I think it goes in one ear and
out the other
you know what I mean that's a good point
yep great just real quick I have a
couple of I was reading an article last
night these are questions that anyone
should know about their significant
other all right I don't even hesitate on
this it means first that's the guy
that's been in a relationship for months
okay Ronnie here you go what is your
anniversary date what is it why won't
you answer May 4th
yeah that sounded like a big hesitation
he was looking for the end there's no
reason a [ __ ] kid why would I answer
these questions I don't know he's a game
all right ask him another question ask
him another question yeah yes Ronnie
yeah okay Ronnie what is Stephanie's
favorite song what is Stephanie's
favorite song hmm I know it's a catchy
song I don't know the exact name of it
Ke$ha that's pretty good no annoying the
anniversary though how many years would
you say it's only two days after her
[ __ ] birthday [ __ ] birthday
Brendon what is Caitlyn's birthday
December 18th see he knows every guy
knows his girlfriend's birthday our wife
what a B what is Kaitlyn's favorite
movie her favorite movie is Love
Actually idiot savant I'm telling ya
Barney - Barney show born yeah purple
dinosaur Ronnie what's Stephanie's favor
come on boom I have no idea good no clue
you really don't know oh you're gonna
[ __ ] I'll put 100 bucks on Brent be
coming with you yeah I think everybody's
betting on Fred there'll be nobody to
bed with it and I don't have what four
months your widow what's her favorite
movie her favorite movie is the mr.
Rogers docume
no wonder she bring ma'amed into this
with his former idea we would wipe the
floor wise I'm telling you no doubt
idiots in fact I want to get paid I
would make $100 bet with more than one
person Wow
yeah you're that confident I'm that
confident look at you Sal you haven't
weighed in who's gonna win well if my
met plate I would bet on my Matt he
would absolutely even though he's only
been with her form right how long you
been with Stephanie almost 12 years 12
years he's got to know her better yeah
if Ronnie can't beat my met I wouldn't
be surprised this guy's pulled some
tricks before he beat Brent in the IQ
test a sharp but between the two I love
Ronnie and I really believe he loves
Stephanie but Ronnie's about
companionship and having fun it's his
way or the highway right so he doesn't
really fully invest and will harness I
really need to know what sheathing
right he doesn't care about her movies
what she ate Brent on the other hand is
totally invested in her yeah I
definitely bet $100 on Ronnie if anyone
wants to take that action do you think
Ronnie's gonna do and this isn't I love
you in Kaitlin Brenda is not a knock on
your relationship I just think the
length of time they've been together the
amount of things that they've been
through then you know you get to a point
in that relationship you've talked about
a lot you've set rules you know he
doesn't know what her favorite movie is
welcome I don't like what I like she
likes what I like just because Brent
answers something confidently doesn't
mean he knows that maybe he would match
Jayson bet $100 on Ronny yeah you wanna
take that money you say Brent's gonna
win
yeah no question no quite to say it I
hate to say it but yeah Ronnie's
strangely quiet it's almost like he blew
a gasket what do you think of what's
going through your head through my head
seriously you are you pissed are you
just clearly you know I didn't think it
was gonna be a wrestling match well it's
fun so why do you have to [ __ ] tear
me apart oh I tell you a parking [ __ ]
comes in with his stupid [ __ ]
questions
no anyone should going around asking why
the [ __ ] interrogate every novel we
better make a [ __ ] backup irani I'm
trying to make an educated bed with the
texting with her and she said she's
always up for a good game I will tell
you know she doesn't even know i texting
i don't believe that's true
gary pride just says that to get on
here's what we learn what would you
listen listen everyone calm down here's
what I was trying to be all I was trying
to say is try not to have a stroke so
upset dude it's just a game I'm just
trying to bet on it get some info they
don't have some fun ready when and see
who's gonna win I'm calm you [ __ ]
[ __ ]
Ronnie if I bet $100 on you is that gone
alright here's what I'm gonna do you
want to do okay
you can paint a Brent on whatever you
gotta do alright I'm straight bet
between Brent and Ronnie on a
head-to-head battle I'm gonna shock you
now I would bet a hundred bucks on
Ronnie I still want a bed 100 on Ronnie
as well only me Ronnie's way but boy oh
boy I want to you I'll take your bet
your bet but you have to take my hundred
dollars by Luis no [ __ ] don't
[ __ ] cost me my money Ronnie I'm
gonna lay a lot of my hundred and when
it's paid Robin make it 200 200 so
someone track this but Mets got 200 with
Robin all in yeah I got her okay take it
easy so far you got 300 well see you
guys know me 200 all right okay take it
easy
no I'm stopping no Christian do you want
I want Brent all right I'll give you a
hundred on that I'll do it I'll do two
alright you got oh my two hundred yeah
Ronnie don't [ __ ] up okay make me proud
her favorite singer is share is NASCAR
and her favorite TV show is Amos and
Andy
[Music]
Stephanie's attitude Ronnie gonna kick
ass wake up [ __ ] up he did a [ __ ]
game bro
Gary the wife whispered out questions
well then what did your girlfriend's
birthday July 10th that is incorrect
texting with Gary
better than you got it wrong
[Music]
to be interesting but knowing someone's
birthday doesn't mean having been with
her during her birthday so we haven't
celebrated her birthday I'll tell you
our anniversary
you got her what's your favorite color
perfect listen I know my wife's favorite
color color is pink what is it you don't
know your girlfriend's birthday
dude this is how she messes with my
sound like me what's your bursary Baskar
due to questions you already got wrong
dude you ought to stay out of this [ __ ]
[Music]
[ __ ] around with you about her
birthday she's lying about her birthday
I think she doesn't see you guys are
making me sound crazy but I don't dude
are you out of your [ __ ] mind pink
has like nificant between her and I so
pink is her favorite color he's so into
himself even the questions for her the
answers have to do with him
right like what's your favorite color
because we're between each other
birthday between each other July 10
shares a different birthday all right
all right
Lynette likes to create doubt weather
isn't any so his girlfriend just sent me
a copy of her passport her birthday is
July 19th
oh it is yeah it's not she's not [ __ ]
with you that's her birthday with him
first of all I said July 20th don't even
try it
yeah it's George Michael I'm gonna say
I'm gonna say okay I'm gonna say it's
definitely it's not last Christmas
it's what's that dananananana and and
what's that Careless Whisper yes you are
correct can I get off the air and talk
to her for a second oh you're out of
your mind
can we all admit that he's disqualified
at this point I mean he doesn't know
anything knows nothing I'm not the guy
who's been with someone 12 years and
riding the animal that's my point
why are you trying to get into a contest
when you've done so poorly on telly you
guys put me on the spot she's messing
with me all right hold on
next week we know Ronny and Brent and
their wives are gonna come in there's
gonna be newlywed game some people are
on Team Ronnie some people are on Team
Brent we'll see what happens Wilma met
his girlfriend be included
it's a cliffhanger everybody loves
newlywed game and I'll tell you what
I'll be tuning in to hear that yeah
that's it from all of us here at the
newlywed game pregame show
we say looking free game that was a
pregame dude you came in like a ball on
fire I don't know what you were yelling
about [ __ ] mother [ __ ] and you
Baldy go [ __ ] yourself with a
double-ended dildo by the way her
favorite movie is the birth of a nation